Film Courage: Are we all procrastinators?
Karl Iglesias: Oh, yeah!
[Laughs] Absolutely.
We’re probably the biggest procrastinators
around and the only reason for that is because
writing is hard.
Creating is hard.
Yeah…I’m probably the biggest procrastinator
there is…Every writer will relate to the
experience of trying to do anything else but
write.
You know, the whole thing about sharpening
your pencils and doing your laundry and cleaning
your house and you know answering emails or
playing solitaire…on one hand it’s something
that’s advised because there is that whole
thing about the creative process where we’re
talking about the gestation period where you’re
supposed to think about your creative problem
and ignore it and do something else that helps
creatively.
Some people think “Okay, that means procrastination.
You can do other things.”
And there is some truth to it.
The problem is if you’re constantly afraid
to write and you’re trying to do other things,
you’ll never write because you’re just
constantly procrastinating.
So there’s got to be a point where you’ve
got to put that aside and actually write and
you’ve got to get over it.
Online there is plenty…I mean there is tons
of advice online about procrastination and
how to avoid it.
Because it’s not just for writing.
It’s for everybody.
Everybody procrastinates.
Anything that is worthwhile to do and is scary
to do, people will procrastinate.
Film Courage: …Well I think you’ve said
that fear is more of what’s at stake, not
writer’s block and that there really isn’t
writer’s block?
Karl Iglesias: There isn’t…right.
At least I do not believe that.
It could be I’m wrong but I think it’s
fear.
Fear of success, fear of failure, fear of
being judged negatively, fear of embarrassing
yourself.
Those are certainly old fears that I relate
to and that I have had to overcome.
Film Courage: Why do you think we put the
label of writer’s block?
Like I’ve heard some people say “Well,
I’m currently blocked right now.”
Like it’s an affliction.
Karl Iglesias: Because it sounds good.
Like “Oh, yes.
I can’t.
Writer’s block is for real artists.
I’m a real artist because I have writer’s
block.”
But a block really just means you’re not
writing.
It means that the words are not coming up
and the words are not coming up because of
the tension that prevents you from writing.
That’s what it is.
So it’s like saying for a plumber…a plumber
never says they have ‘Plumber’s Block,’
right?
They just go to do their job.
It’s about doing your job.
Showing up at your job.
You have to understand that writing is a job,
whether you get paid or not, you have to show
up to your desk and you have to put your butt
on the chair and you’ve got to type words.
So that’s what it is.
We use it as an excuse, we say it really is
a fear of writing, fear of whatever all those
procrastinating things I’ve said but it
doesn’t sound good to say “Oh, I’m afraid
of it.”
It sounds a lot better to say “I am blocked”
because then people can go “Oh, poor you!
Yeah, you’re an artist.”
So it sounds better but it’s really just
fear.
And again, there is plenty material out there
on how to overcome those fears.
It’s all psychological stuff we have to
overcome.
Film Courage: Do you see a lot of that fear
resurface once someone has really gone out
there and either pitched or shared their material
or had (quote) “people in their peer group”
give them feedback?
Karl Iglesias: Yes…and it’s usually because
the writing…[people] didn’t respond to
the writing as much as they wanted to.
They really expected the pat on the back and
being told how great it was and chances are
it wasn’t as good.
So really it’s up to you.
It depends on how thick your skin is.
It’s about how much you want this.
How much you’re conscious enough to understand
that feedback is important and that you should
take it as it is.
You should look at it as constructive criticism
and pay attention to it and re-write it and
make it better.
It’s all about making it better.
You’ve really got to know how to do it.
It’s a big part of the Hollywood job as
a screenwriter.
I mean I’ve never heard of something just
being a first draft.
I mean [you hear] of 30 drafts or 40 drafts.
So they’re constantly [revising] and you’ve
got to be able to do that.
If you’re the type of writer who does not
like to be told that something is wrong and
want to say “No, this is the way it is.
It’s my art and that is the way it is.”
You shouldn’t be writing screenplays.
You should be writing novels or plays.
That’s really the only two professions where
the writer is king, really.
Unless you’re doing television because the
writer is king there, too.
But mostly novelists and playwrights where,
yeah the editor can tell you something is
not working and you can take it or leave it,
but it’s really you that has the final say
on that.
Then you should do that.
I think people who have thin skin or are very
sensitive to creative feedback should not
be screenwriters.
I mean, they are in for a really frustrating
experience, if that’s the case.
Question for the Viewers: What are your thoughts
on writer’s block?